is this can I ask one one of the HBO
shows in development can you tell us
about any of those by the way blood moon
is wrapped something has I I I can't uh
go on there's probably an HBO agent in
the in the auditorium even now um I can
say as I have said before we we started
out with a number of different ideas all
of them prequels um one show um which
I've been calling the long night but HBO
keeps saying it's not titled yet so the
show that's not called The Long KN uh
yet has just finished uh filming up in
Belfast and is now and and other places
not just Belfast Italy as well and uh
Jane Goldman is the writer and the
showrunner on that uh you you've
probably be been familiar with her work
she uh was the script writer on several
of the um X-Men movies she did kickass
and she did the um The Kingsmen both
Kingsmen uh thing she she scripted Neil
gaiman's Stardust so she's a very
experienced uh
screenwriter and she's done this story
and it is set you know 5,000 years in
the past of West Ros so way way way
before the events of Game of Thrones and
that that's the one that is furthest
along at the moment and it's in
pre-production and right now it's just a
pilot but it it's Got U Naomi Watson at
starring it's got Miranda Richardson a
lot of other very uh exciting actors and
uh we'll probably be finding out in the
next couple months whether HBO is
actually going to order a full full
series of that that is very and
meanwhile we have two other Pilots that
are also in active development at some
stage and hopefully uh in the near
future one or both of them will be uh
green lit to shoot a pilot and we may
get more than one westro show on the air
wow the
realm do you know what the realm
is it's the Thousand Blades of agon's
enemies a story we agree to tell each
other over and over till we forget that
it's a
lie what's up ladies and gentlemen
welcome back for another Game of Thrones
in a song of ice and fire update video
in this video I want to go over the new
information we have regarding the
original Game of Thrones successor show
known as blood moon we now have what
looks like our first official images
from the cancelled show the new photos
look like images from that InFamous
first episode now for those of you who
don't know or might not remember blood
moon was the first successor show to
Game of Thrones this was the show they
wanted to make immediately after Game of
Thrones final season ended now according
to HBO's own website the blood moon
series would be set thousands of years
before the events in Game of Thrones the
show would highlight what happened
during westeros's desent from the Golden
Age of Heroes into its Darkest Hour
during What would most likely be the
first long night and they said only one
thing was for sure from the horrifying
secrets of westeros's History to the
true origins of the white walkers the
mysteries of the East to the Starks of
Legend it's not the story we think we
know it sounds like this series would
have shown us exactly what happened in
Westeros thousands of years ago it would
have brought all of those incredible
Legends to life now I don't know about
all of you but I was fascinated by this
idea and if you've been watching all of
my videos over the years then you know I
was looking forward to this show the
most I was devastated after HBO made the
announcement they were no longer moving
forward with this show now I'm sure some
of you might be wondering why they
stopped making the series well according
to their official announcement at the
time HBO's executiv said it was a a
difficult show to make because there
wasn't a whole lot of information
written about what happened thousands of
years ago in fact George R Martin had
only written eight lines worth of
information about those events he said
the writers were left having to invent
nearly all of the scenes however he also
said although it was very hard to
develop there wasn't actually that many
issues wrong with it it wasn't
unwatchable or horrible or anything like
that it was very wellmade and looked
extraordinary but it did not take me to
the same place as the or orig series it
was lacking the rich layers the original
series had now George R Martin who still
hasn't seen the first episode said it
was a very difficult assignment most of
the first episode revolved around a
wedding of a southern house and a
northern house and it got into the whole
history of the white walkers the show
actually doesn't sound that bad based on
what we've heard so far but it must have
been awful because HBO wasted nearly $35
million making its first and only
episode that's more than three times the
amount they spent on Game of Thrones
first episode which was roughly $10
million to make I think there might be
another reason why HBO was ready to walk
away from a $35 million investment
according to a number of different
sources the long night series ran into
some major issues When developing the
children of the forest rather than
making them look like the magical leafy
green figures from Game of Thrones they
went with black actors instead in this
new version of the story they wanted to
have a black race stand in as the
indigenous inhabitants of Westeros and
it would be a curse that turns them all
into the children of the forest
meanwhile all of the Rich and noble
families from Westeros would be white
not only that but it also says these
black children of the forest would
behave like barbarians I think most of
you should see how that would be an
issue if all the whites are rich and
Noble while the blacks are barbarics who
are cursed I'm not sure who thought that
would be a great idea rather than fixing
the issue HBO must have thought it would
be better to walk away from this $35
million disaster after they did announce
they were shutting down blood moon they
immediately followed that up with a new
announcement that house of the Dragon
was getting a full series order so it
wasn't all bad news on that day now I
want to have a look at the new photos
because it gives us our first glimpse of
what this $35 million episode looked
like as you can see we have Naomi watt
standing inside what seems to be cast
Rock The ancestral seat of house
lanister although Naomi Watts is a
natural blonde I always assumed she was
going to be a member from how Stark
the description of the show made it
sound like it would focus on the Starks
of Legend and the mysteries in the north
I guess I'd always assumed it would be
similar to Game of Thrones where they
would have the lead actor or actress be
the face of house Stark now I do wonder
how she would fit into the show we still
don't know who her character was she
could be someone from the casterly the
Lannisters or even L the clever's mother
or sibling how would this fit into the
origins of the White Walkers and the
children of the forest now George R
Martin said the first episode was was
going to focus on a wedding of a
southern house and a northern house I
now wonder if they were going to marry
someone from casty Rock and Winterfell
it would have been very interesting to
learn how Stark and maybe House
Lannister were wed thousands of years
ago we also have some new images of how
Starks men and boat we have seen an
image like this before back when they
were filming the episode but now we have
a better look at the style of boats and
uniforms you can also see how Stark
sigil is slightly different from the one
we have seen in Game of Thrones now
outside of this we've also heard the
show what introduced the order of the
green men the green men are a sacred
order who guard the a of faces in the
God's eye this does make sense
considering there would be such a heavy
focus on the children of the forest who
also inhabit the aisle of faces this is
another reason why I was so excited for
the show I've always been fascinated by
the mystery surrounding the order of the
green men the aisle of faces the
children of the forest and everything in
the north that's from how Stark's
Origins the making of Winterfell and the
wall the origins of the Knights watch
the 13th Lord Commander the knights King
White Walkers and everything else out
Beyond the Wall this show really was
right up my alley because it would have
highlighted all the things I love most
about A Song of Ice and Fire all these
new photos do is make me want to see the
show even more although I know it would
have been a mess the show basically
would have had to stand on its own since
there's no Source material from this
moment in westerosi history somehow
someway I do hope they're able to
explore this idea again now I could
always get the answers I want if George
R Martin would ever finish the damn
story but we all know the status on that
with all of that being said leave me
your thoughts down below what do you
think about these new photos do they
make you want to see the show even more
or are you glad they decided to move on
to something else I'd like to hear what
you have to say as always I want to
thank all of you for watching another
video I hope you all have a great day I
will see you again very soon
bye
[Music]